Check out this trade right here. I'm up
over $5,000
on it with a simple, repeatable strategy
that I execute every day. But, this is
something you can start doing with just
$4 and slowly scale. I started with this
myself making under $100 per trade and
slowly scaling up over the years to now
making over $5,000 in a single trade.
It's the easiest way for new traders to
become consistently profitable as fast
as possible. Over the years, I've
discovered a simple principle and built
a whole strategy around it that
completely changed my trading and other
people's trading as well. Every time I
tried to learn a new strategy, add more
indicators, or level up with something
new, I actually made less money. Trading
feels like it should be complicated, and
as humans, we love to make things
complicated. But, that's exactly what
sabotages most traders. The traders who
struggled the longest are usually the
ones bouncing from strategy to strategy,
trying everything, and thinking that the
more you learn, the more profitable you
will become. But, this is not the case
with trading. The turning point for me
was when I stopped trying to master the
market and focused on one simple
money-making pattern and repeat it every
single day. The same execution, the same
checklist, and the same setup. It's so
stupid simple, it seems like it
shouldn't work. I stopped caring about
all the other moves the market was
making where I could have made money,
and for the first time ever, I started
actually becoming confident consistently
in my own trading. And the best part is,
you can actually start doing this with a
really small account risking less than
$50 per trade and scale over time to
where I am now risking $1,500 per trade,
making over $5,000 in a single trade.
And I'm going to continue to scale up
from there. And it doesn't require
sitting at the charts all day. Most
days, I actively watch the markets 45 to
60 minutes, and then I'm done. So, in
this video, I'm going to show you
exactly how the strategy works, how to
repeat it daily, and how to scale it the
right way. So, you can go from trading a
small account to creating a trading
career. So, here's the strategy. Every
single morning, I open up my charts to
the S&P 500 Futures. The first thing I'm
looking for isn't an entry, it's
location. I'm going to the 15-minute
chart and marking out key areas of
support and resistance. These are the
zones where the market has reacted
before, where buyers and sellers have
already stepped in, and where price is
most likely to reverse again. This gives
me the big-picture bias. And once I've
mapped that out, I drop down to a
1-minute chart. And this is where most
traders go wrong, where I went wrong,
actually. They start scanning for every
potential move, every reversal, every
continuation, or every breakout. They
don't want to miss out on any possible
money that could be made that day. I
don't do that. I wait for four specific
patterns to line up, which together make
up my five-step entry checklist. If
those criteria aren't met, I don't
trade. If the market doesn't fit the
checklist, I shut down for the day and
go do something else. That's what makes
this powerful. It removes decision
fatigue. It removes emotion, and it
removes that self-sabotage.
It's simple, it's rule-based, and it
takes 45 to 60 2 a day, and it fits into
real life. You can go do this with a
full-time job. So, before I walk you
through the step-by-step process of how
I find and execute these trades yourself
with a real example, we need to talk
about how to trade and scale your
account the right way. First off, I am
trading the futures markets instead of
trading something like options, forex,
or crypto. I found it way simpler
trade what's called futures. You can
start with an extremely low amount of
risk or a small account because you're
actually what trading what's called the
micro futures contracts. Giving you a
leverage similar to options without the
complexity involved that comes with
trading options. And also, you don't
need a lot of money in your account to
day trade. It has the leverage of
options but the simplicity of trading
shares or stocks. If you buy, it goes
up, you make money. And if you sell it
and it goes down, you make money. It
keeps trading simple but allows you to
start with a really small account. A
platform that works perfectly for this
is called NinjaTrader. You can start
demo trading, which I always recommend
doing first when learning trading or new
platform. This allows you to practice
reading the market and trading. I'll
leave a link below for you to get
started with that as I think it's the
best futures platform in my opinion.
I've used it for over 5 years at this
point myself. It's extremely powerful
for trading. Now, let me show you that
trade where I made over $5,000 in just
15 minutes in the morning using this
exact step process I execute every day
so you can learn it yourself and start
to scale your own account. So, the first
thing I do every morning is I look at a
15-minute chart of the S&P 500 futures.
This is the main asset I trade every
morning and I want to see on a 15-minute
chart, cuz I'm looking for trades on a
1-minute chart, what is the big picture?
This is important for any strategy you
do is what is the bias and the current
mode the market is in that you're
looking at. Right now, the market is in
pretty choppy, volatile, back and forth
with some moves down, some big moves up,
and then over the last couple of days
it's kind of more in a sideways range.
And so, keeping that in mind going into
trading and looking for, okay, what is
the future of the market going to do, I
find it way easier to assume that, okay,
well, the market is likely to continue
what it's done in the past. So, most
likely, because the market's been kind
of choppy here, it makes it likely that
it will continue to do that. And so,
first thing I want to do though is I
want to look at the major resistance
levels and support levels in the market.
Where are the big extremes, you know,
based off of it touching those areas
multiple times and selling off, and also
the extreme low down here. And then as
well, I'll kind of zoom in to look at
the last couple days and think, okay,
well, there's kind of a bottom here,
there's some swings here, the market's
currently trading right here. And so,
I'm going to think, okay, I'm going to
draw levels based off of the overnight
lows here, the overnight and
pre-yesterday highs, and also something
to consider is also a trend line. Like
this looks like it could be having a
upward resistance trend line. That is
something that is totally normal as
well. Um the market kind of was having
one right here as it kind of is in this
opening wedge pattern. And so, this
helps me know where to look for the
reversals. As the market shoots up in
this level, I want to see a potential
reversal because it's coming to an area
where there's a resistance zone and a
resistance trend line. If you want a
little more information on how I
specifically draw these more in depth,
I'll leave a link to a video up here.
And another thing that I look at every
morning is the pre-market news. I use a
website called Forex Factory. It's
totally free. And all I do is I set it
to US only. And then it shows you in the
morning what news is coming in. Because
you want to know every day is there high
impact news coming in that I need to pay
attention to, low impact, or medium
impact. Right now, the market is very
volatile from a lot of time the news in
the Middle East and anytime the
president speaks. These are massive
things that can move the market. And so
you want to know what is happening that
day going into trading. So you don't
have any surprises that happen. And so
once all that happens, I essentially
want to watch the market open and see
how it reacts to its upwards trend or
this level and look for a reversal. I
found it way simpler over time to look
for just reversals because again, it
simplified things. And reversals
actually give you really good
risk-reward ratios. What I like to go
for is a 1:3 or 1:2 risk-reward ratios.
This allows your win rate to not be that
high. You only need like a 30 or 40% win
rate if you're getting two or three
times your risk because you're making a
lot more money when you win versus when
you lose. And so over time, if the
market is coming up to a resistance zone
here and I think we're going to sell
off, I can risk something like let's say
if I enter in right here and I put my
stop loss up here, I can risk $100 right
here. And then if I target all the way
down here, I could get $300
from that trade. And so that would be a
really good favorable risk-reward ratio
and something that you can consistently
make money from over time if your
accuracy is good. That is why I really
like looking for reversal trades because
the risk-reward ratio is very, very
profitable. You want the math to be in
your favor when it comes to trading.
Having something like a one-to-one
risk-reward ratio or even worse where
you're risking $100 to make 50, that
means your win rate has to be extremely
high. You have to be extremely accurate
with every trade. And every trade has to
work out well because if you're at a
negative risk-reward ratio, then you
risk something like $100 to make 50,
every lose you take takes two wins to
make up. And mentally, that is really
hard to deal with. And I speak from
experience on that one. And so, the
first thing when I go to a one-minute
chart is I want to see the market open.
So, the market opens at 9:30 Eastern
Standard Time, and I want to see it come
up to one of those big picture levels.
And so, here is that resistance zone
that I was looking at. And so, the
market has already come up to that
level. And so, that's step one checked
off. And then, next what I want to see
is how it reacts to this level. Because
just because something moves up into a
level doesn't mean that it's it's going
to immediately reverse. A lot of the
times, these levels can break and the
market continues higher because the
trend is so strong. And so, that's why I
have built this checklist to try and
essentially, what it does is it helps
you easily identify when something is
likely to actually reverse off of a
level versus continue at that level. And
so, once it comes up to the level,
that's the first thing. The most
important thing, honestly, is the big
picture. What does it do when it comes
up to one of these levels? I want to see
it come up to this resistance line, and
I want to see it potentially hit that
and start to reverse. And as well,
bringing in the bigger picture is
because we're in kind of a sideways
choppy range, well, I would expect to us
if we're going to continue doing that,
as we come up here, we're probably going
to sell off and reverse just because
it's staying in the methodical mode that
the market's in. I like to treat the
market that it's going to continue what
it's going to do 80% of the time. That's
just a good number to go off of. Most of
the time it's going to do what it was
previously doing. And so, the next kind
of step that I'm looking for is what I
like to call an unhealthy move. A super
easy way to look at that is if I pull up
a 5-minute chart of the S&P 500 futures,
I have something called a fair value gap
indicator. It's It's basically creating
these green boxes. And so, what it does
is it helps you identify when a huge
unhealthy move happens. Essentially, the
indicator just kind of goes off of
basically how big a candlestick is
compared to the previous candlesticks.
It essentially makes this gap between
these candles. And what that does though
is an unhealthy move, how it works is
the market essentially gets
overextended. And so, it has to reverse
that move. And you can see it
essentially gives back most of this
green box that it created. And so, this
is what I like to look for as it comes
up, it produces unhealthy move signals,
and then you get a snapback reversal.
That doesn't mean that necessarily the
uptrend is over. You can see here the
uptrend after had that snapback, it
continued with the big picture trend to
the upside. But, that doesn't mean you
can't profit from a snapback like this.
And then also potentially look for, you
can see there's little red boxes,
meaning there was overextension to the
downside, that there is potential to
capture this move up as well. So, that's
why I like trading reversals. And if we
look at this market right here, you can
see here is an unhealthy move. As well
as this was a big spike up. And so what
I'd like to see is if this gets going,
we can give this move all the way back
down to here, which is a great potential
in a target, and then it could bounce
here, or it could continue to the
downside. And so that's kind of step two
in my checklist. That's the catalyst
that I think makes it likely for a very
clean reversal to happen in a big way.
And usually, these work out better to
the downside versus the long side
because when the market sells off, it
sells off very, very quickly. And
volatility is good for us because if it
sells off and then continues to sell
off, you can get a very big trade very
quickly, which we'll start to see in a
minute. Now, the third thing that I like
to see is Well, essentially, I'm betting
that if I'm looking for a reversal here,
I'm betting that this uptrend is
starting to end. And I'm betting that
it's going to become a downtrend. And so
that's very, very hard to do. And so I
like to wait until the market has
actually shown me that that downtrend is
started. And so if we look at a super
easy way to do that is just look at the
swings, right? There's a swing high,
swing low, swing high, swing low, swing
high, swing low, swing high, swing low.
So,
potentially, this one's still forming.
But just looking at that, you know, a
uptrend makes higher highs and higher
lows. And then when a downtrend starts,
well, a downtrend is signified by lower
lows and lower highs. And so I would
want to see this essentially start to do
that. And so this right here is a great
initial signal that it's made a lower
low than this one back here. And this
selling pressure with these big
candlesticks is also a good sign. But to
me, that's not enough confirmation. I
want to actually see the market make an
attempt to continue higher here because
what that shows me is the market can
have a little bit bigger of a pullback
here in a strong uptrend and continue
higher. And so, I want to see
essentially it attempts to continue
higher, and that continuation actually
fail. And I want to get in below if it
makes essentially a new low because to
me that's confirmation from here and
confirmation from here. And so, if I
kind of zoom in a little bit to see how
this plays out, you can see that's right
there. This is a good attempt. This big
bullish candlestick is the market kind
of attempting to continue higher. But
then right immediately right after it,
boom, we have a big red candlestick that
is showing almost instantaneous
rejection of this attempt to continue
higher. And so, to me I'm thinking,
okay, this looks really good. Multiple
things are checked off. Now, I have to
think about how I want to enter into a
trade in real time, right? Cuz this is
happening in real time, and I want to
get in when it kind of breaks this low.
Now, in this trade specifically, because
if you also look at this, the market was
a little choppy right here, I elected to
actually wait for this to break the low
and to see if there was going to be a
little bit of a pullback, and then I'll
put my order in right below that. And I
enter in on a stop market order. What it
essentially does is it jumps you in
right as the market hits that exact
price. Basically, it inputs a market
order versus a limit order. And so, this
is exactly what I wanted to see. Is the
market essentially pushed lower, had
this big rejection candlestick. So, you
know, we trapped people to the highs.
Trapped. Potentially, this could turn
into a trap to the lows and shoot us
higher. But I want to see, well, if it
does that, but that fails and breaks
this, I think that's great confirmation
that we're going to continue to the
downside. And so, I have my stop order
there with three contracts on the S&P
500 futures. Essentially, another thing
I'm looking at here is that looking at,
okay, I just drew this little minor
support zone. Are we bouncing off of
this little zone? But I think once we
break that, it opens up the door to give
this whole unhealthy move back up. And
it can happen very, very quickly. It's a
big void in the market in terms of
volume and support that will happen very
quickly. And then so I put my stop loss
up here. I'm risking about $1,500 on
this trade. And so I'm looking for
either down here as an initial target.
That would be around 2x. And then if we
continue lower, I like to kind of have a
fluid trailing stop because sometimes
these trades can really get going
quickly. And so we had kind of a big
spike right here, and I actually moved
my stop loss down a little bit cuz I
thought, well, if this spike reverses up
to here, I'm fine getting out of the
trade. Essentially, I'm taking a little
risk off the table, managing based on
what I see. There, I've moved my stop
loss now to break even, thinking that,
okay, if this turns into a little double
bottom right here, I actually want to
get out. Because in a way, we have
already given up most of this move, and
that is an initial soft target for me.
And I'm thinking that, well, I if this
is really going to get going, it's going
to happen quickly. Again, because
talking about on the short side, shorts
happen very quickly. And generally, the
best trades happen very quickly. And so
there, once it makes a new low, I kind
of like to move my stop with the swings.
Um and I'm just kind of looking to see,
okay, how does this trend play out?
There's kind of this downtrend now in
play. We are almost perfectly at this
spot where I would expect us to start
potentially bouncing as a minor support.
The more major support is down here.
Actually, if I pull up kind of that big
picture again, as this trade is going,
it's kind of here, right? It's breaking
here. I'm looking to see, okay, well,
this is that previous lows of the
market. Are we going to potentially hit
those overnight lows, and that's the
next support level. And so, I think if
we break this, it opens the door to down
here. And so, a lot of times it's kind
of you got to be patient, you know, I
like to give the market some wiggle room
if I think it has the potential to have
a big move. And so, once it kind of
starts to you can see here, these are
1-minute candlesticks as they kind of
zoom through this, it starts to
accelerate pretty, pretty fast. And so,
for my management style as a beginner
and someone new to this strategy, I
would highly suggest trying to just go
for two or three fixed profit target,
like a a fixed profit target of two
times your risk or three times your risk
because fluidly managing a a trade like
this with real money in real time is
difficult. It takes time. And I have
different ways that I do it based on
what the market does. And so, right now
because we've got starting to accelerate
so fast, I'm moving my stop-loss at
every time a candlestick closes, I move
it above the high because each one of
these candlesticks is like a thousand
dollars. That's huge. And so, as much as
I would love to continue to stay in
this, just like over here with an
unhealthy move on the way up, how it can
rapidly reverse, this is now becoming an
unhealthy move on the downside. And so,
if I give it too much wiggle room, like
if I had my stop all the way up here to
where waiting for it to break this trend
line, well, if it reverses super quickly
up here, I would be giving back a like
half of my trade in profits, and you
don't want to do that. I like to once it
kind of gets down to 3x, which is kind
of right here, this is 3x my profit, I
like to tighten up my trailing stop
because that's where I'm I'm happy with
taking a trade off, but I also like to
if this is just going to keep printing
candlesticks lower, I am happy to stay
in it as well. But based on as well, you
don't want to always think about your
risk reward, you want to be thinking
about, okay, where am I in the move of
the market? And if we look at kind of
the bigger picture here, well, this is
at the lows here, right? This is this
support zone. So, I'm expecting that it
to reverse here. It could continue down
to this next one, but it could also
bounce here and mess around for a while
before it continues lower, and I don't
want to risk the profits I already have.
And so, essentially from there, my stop
loss, you know, it it looks like it's
going to keep going, but I get knocked
out here at about three times my risk
for about $5,000, and it's a great
trade. Now, I've got a free PDF guide
that you can download that has more
detailed on this five-step entry
checklist. You can get it via this QR
code or the link in the description.
It's completely free. Now, if you want
to learn more about futures and my
strategy, check out this video right
here. It'll go into a ton of detail with
trade examples and how to grow your
account with futures.